[Music]
all year long
researchers at hundreds of hospitals
around the world
collect samples from flu patients and
send them to top virology experts with
one goal to design the vaccine for the
next flu season but why do we need a new
one every year vaccines for diseases
like mumps and rubella offer a lifetime
of protection with two shots early in
life what's so special about the flu two
factors make the flu a tough target
first there are more than 100 subtypes
of the influenza virus and the ones in
circulation change from season to season
and second the flus genetic code allows
it to mutate more quickly than many
other viruses the flu spreads by turning
a hosts own cells into viral production
factories when the virus is engulfed by
a host cell it expels its genetic
material which makes its way to the
nucleus their cellular machinery that
normally copies the hosts genes starts
replicating viral genes instead creating
more and more copies of the virus new
viruses are repackaged and crammed into
the cell until it bursts sending freshly
minted influenza viruses out to infect
additional cells most viruses follow
this script the trick with the flu is
that its genetic material isn't DNA but
a similar compound called RNA and RNA
viruses can mutate much faster when
cells synthesize DNA a built-in
proofreader recognizes and corrects
mistakes but the RNA synthesis mechanism
doesn't have this failsafe if errors
creep in they stick around creating new
variants of the virus why is this a
problem because vaccines depend on
recognition
the flu vaccine includes some of the
same substances called antigens found on
the surface of the virus itself the body
identifies those fragments as foreign
and responds by producing compounds
called antibodies tailor-made to match
the antigens when a vaccinated person
encounters the actual virus the
pre-programmed antibodies help the
immune system identify the threat and
mobilize quickly to prevent an infection
those antigens are different for every
strain of influenza
if vaccination has prepared the immune
system for one strain a different one
may still be able to sneak by even
within the same strain of flu those
rapid genetic mutations can change the
surface compounds enough that the
antibodies may not recognize them to
make things even more complicated
sometimes two different strains combine
to create an entirely new hybrid virus
all of this makes vaccinating for the
flu like trying to hit a moving
transforming target that's why
scientists are constantly collecting
data about which strains are circulating
and checking to see how much those
strains have mutated from previous
year's versions twice annually the World
Health Organization pulls together
experts to analyze all that data holding
one meeting for each hemisphere the
scientists determine which strains to
include in that season's vaccine picking
four for the quadrivalent vaccine in use
today in spite of the flus evasive
maneuvers in recent years the group's
predictions have been almost always
correct
even when flu strains mutate further the
vaccine is often close enough that a
vaccinated person who catches the flu
anyway will have a milder and shorter
illness than they would otherwise
vaccination also helps protect other
people in the community who may not be
medically eligible for the shot by
preventing those around them from
carrying the virus this is called herd
immunity the flu shot can't give you the
flu it contains an inactivated virus
that isn't capable of making you sick
you might feel tired and achy
after getting it but that's not an
infection it's your normal immune
response to the vaccine some parts of
the world use instead of a shot an
inhaled vaccine that contains a weakened
live virus this is also safe for the
vast majority of people only those with
impaired immune systems would be at risk
but they're typically not given live
vaccines meanwhile scientists are
working to develop a universal flu
vaccine that would protect against any
strain even mutated ones but until then
the hunt for next year's vaccine is on
did you enjoy this lesson if so please
consider supporting our nonprofit
mission by visiting patreon.com slash
Ted Edie
[Music]